RIPPED FROM TODAY'S INTERNET
HEADLINES, IT'S RAPID REFRESH.
NOW, SHIRTLESS BUFOON AND ONE OF
COMEDY CENTRAL'S TOP CANADIANS
TO WATCH, JUSTIN BIEBER, TURNED
21 OVER THE WEEKEND.
GUYS, HE CAN FINALLY ENJOY ADULT
BEVERAGES LEGALLY.
HIS FIRST BEER IS GOING TO BE SO
EXCITING FOR HIM.
AS EXPECTED, HE CELEBRATED BY
THROWING HIMSELF A HUGE BASH AND
ALL OF HIS BEST FRIENDS ON HIS
PAYROLL WERE ON ATTENDANCE.
LET'S LOOK AT THE VIDEO HE
POSTED ON FAHLO.
♪[50 CENT'S "IN DA CLUB"PLAYS]
>> CHRIS: LOOK AT THAT!
LOOK AT LITTLE SHIRTLESS BEEBS
THERE, YAY SPARKLERS!
SPARKLERS! OW, OW, OW, OW!
OW, OW, OW. I SHOULD PUT A SHIRT
ON. OW, OW, OW.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY, JUSTIN. YOU
LIVED LONGER THAN ANY OF US
THOUGHT YOU WOULD.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> HE'S FINALLY OLD ENOUGH TO
HOLD A SPARKLER.
>> CHRIS HE IS FIANLLY, CAN
LEGALLY HOLD A SPARKLER.
THIS VIDEO IS JUST A SMALL TASTE
OF THE DEBAUCHERY THAT I AM SURE
OCCURRED. SO COMEDIANS WHAT ARE
SOME OTHER NONSPARKLER THINGS
THAT HAPPENED AT JUSTIN BIEBER'S
21ST BIRTHDAY BASH.
JEN KIRKMAN.
>> I THINK WHAT YOU DIDN'T
SEE WAS THAT THEY THEN
STUCK THE DONKEY ASS THAT THEY
HAD'S ASS TO DISLODGE THE
BALLOON FULL OF COCAINE.
>> CHRIS: YES, DEFINITELY.
POINTS.
>> I DON'T WANT TO MAKE FUN OF
HIM.
>> CHRIS: IT'S LITEARLLY A
COCAINE MULE.
LITERALLY.
>> BEEBS, I'VE MET BEEBS BEFORE,
WE'RE TIGHT. SO, SORRY BEEBS.
>> CHRIS: WHAT?
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S WHERE DID SHE GET
THOSE PANTS?
>> CHRIS: 100 POINTS TO DOUG
BENSON. SO NICE.
BARATUNDE.
>> RIGHT AFTER THAT HIS BLACK
FRIENDS LET HIM WIN AT
BASKETBALL.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY. HAPPY BIRTHDAY.